guys we just got off a live stream
discussing Don's live stream and a lot
of people in our chat were saying that
he scammed people out of 100 200 dollars
we didn't want to leave it off the spot
without any evidence so this is the
alleged clip that we will react to
all right I promise if someone donates a
hundred dollars I'll go to the three
Muslims right now I promise I promise
I promise I promise
foreign
this this thing that I used to pull up
the super Chats on the screen Loki be
making this like Chat thing I got crash
no
bro come on I'm trying to Sebastian
Charles I saw the hundred dollars you
won't that's a fact I won't
that's a fact because I said a thousand
dollars you need that's 900 more you
need
I said a thousand dollars
I said a thousand dollars
I said a thousand dollars
you gave me a hundred dollars bro
a thousand dollars has four zeros not
three
bro is he is he stupid a thousand has
three zeros not four
[Laughter]
but whatever bro
y'all can't count either y'all need a
dictionary and y'all can't count
a thousand dollars has four zeros not
three
okay account
nah bro that's not lying what y'all call
it in Islam that ain't lying that's it
what y'all call it uh lying in Islam
Takia that was some tequila
laughs
yo hey I'm gonna make sure I put that
hundred dollars in my church offering
this week I'm gonna I'm I'm gonna take
that hundred dollars and I'm gonna write
from Islam and drop it in the church
offering this Sunday y'all did that
perfect dummies
it's possible that someone who has
committed murder to be fine God
be saved I do believe that's possible
yes
we don't go to hell for a sin for being
Sinners we're all Sinners and God says
in the Bible that if you've broken the
lease of my own laws it is as if you've
broken them all so in God's eyes if
you've ever lied like I just did to
these Muslims I'm gonna have to pray for
forgiveness you ain't no different than
a murderer
you know a fornicator all of that
God will forgive me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
I feel kind of bad now I do feel kind of
bad because like you know I said I
promise
but this time my pinky promise
if you donate a hundred dollars more
if you donate one more hundred dollars
I'll go I pranky promise I promise
really for real I'm gonna hit him up
right now 100 dollars more pinky promise
come on come on you want to do it
you don't wanna you don't want to see it
happen I don't happen
[Music]
nah for real though like I do feel bad I
feel bad I feel bad I feel bad I feel
bad I do I do feel bad now for real for
real a hundred dollars more I'm there
bro
I'm there bro the Muslim apologist
let's have a conversation I gotta look
you up I don't know I do believe it's
possibly some like genuine Muslims out
there that got like you know possibly I
don't know
that that will be like have some
integrity
but right now look at how y'all behave
you're y'all are animals
y'all so so foaming at the mouth
you just gave a hundred dollars to that
enemy
that I'm about to put in my church
offering plate
that's how desperate y'all are I can't
you know what they say
you know someone you don't want to get
in a fight with a desperate man because
he ain't got nothing to lose
no honor no integrity
no principles
ugh
and I know if one of these Muslims came
and caught me and shot me and set me up
not a single one of you would speak out
against them you go in the comments
section under Anonymous profile and be
like
had it coming
I don't got no love for y'all you know
what I'm saying
[Laughter]
what's this what's this right now
I wasn't even a Muslim bro that was out
there for the Muslims Sebastian
you fell for the Trap card that wasn't
for you come on man
thanks for the 200 though
dance with a 200 though I make it up to
you
with a W stream
El Don L racist you calling me racist
bro
wow you know I thought Muslims were
super like hyper masculine you really
playing the victimhole card bro like a
woman that's tough bro
that's tough but hey
that's kind of crazy
yeah this was this was a great stream I
I think I'll end it here
uh to my Muslim viewers
I hope you enjoyed the Stream
you guys love ya
keep doing what you do
[Music]
I want to begin by saying I genuinely
believe he's actually losing his mind I
honestly think he's mentally unstable
and I think he's slowly but surely
losing his mind he played a song and
looked into the camera and laughed like
he's some anime or Disney villain it
felt cool like and no I'm dead serious
bro look look go watch it go watch it
back he he thinks he's cool with music
and the literally Evil theme music in
the background playing laughing at the
fact that he just scammed a Muslim who
was actually even a Muslim out of not
one but two hundred dollars it's crazy
bro and the fact that he held this
narrative afterwards he's like and this
is what's really funny I thought I
thought Muslims were supposed to be
masculine and you know manly and so on
and so forth why are you playing the
victim card do you remember Dawn what
you said and did after the first
discussion with man you sat there about
to cry at the fact that you got jumped
into a debate with a scholar of the
Bible in the Quran who is a Muslim and
then this triggered your entire mental
breakdown and hatred for Islam
um was that not the victim card where
you cried to sneak over him being a bad
friend because he disagreed with you on
a point that is very clearly obviously
against you and now we're playing the
victim card Muslims weren't crying about
it
it was your friend from your Bible study
Sebastian who said how are you going to
do me like that and you said not that
you'll give the money back that you'll
reward him with a W stream that is
pathetic
absolutely bro absolutely I don't know
what to say bro my blood's boiling you
know like deep within I'm just like
there's if he you know you know when you
said he's gone insane
if he doesn't see the cognitive
dissonance hypocrisy and what he's
saying saying that you know y'all don't
have integrity morals character you know
I see what you're doing bro yeah are you
are you that cerebrally dense that you
don't even see the cognitive dissonance
what you're saying he has a wife bro
she's pregnant right now you know he has
a daughter too
and it's like bro this is the type of
Father you want to become
and you saw the thing about the I don't
even want to get into Christianity in
this book because this is a quick
reaction but yeah where he said can
people that off other people right
because I don't want to get this
demonetized can they go to heaven he
said of course
yeah so how do you expect someone that
just has faith in Jesus and doesn't have
any accountability how do you expect
someone like that to even have morality
bro how do you expect someone like that
to even even have anything of character
and honor you don't yeah 100 you can and
it's not just before anyone jumps on
this it's not a problem of a murderer
getting to Heaven you know there's no
problem with that it's the problem of a
murder going to heaven a murderer going
to heaven just because they believe in
something
with no accountability he said himself
that he just needs to you know repent
and ask forgiveness and whatever just
move on in life because he believed
Jesus died for his sins after scamming
someone out of two hundred dollars that
is pathetic and if you want to talk
about honor and integrity and that stuff
why don't you take
yourself who so apparently you know has
so much integrity and is so you know uh
so much of a man back on our stream come
discuss with us Friday like we invited
you on the Stream
and BMN if you're going to talk about
integrity you will never find the three
Muslims doing this kind of thing you
will never in a million years find the
three Muslims scamming anyone out of
anything and I don't say this because of
us I'm gonna say this because our
religion the three Muslims have a at 10
of everything we make is going towards
building massage it houses for Allah not
because we're so cool or great or
amazing we're nothing we are nothing
honestly but because that's what Islam
teaches us to do and if you Don want to
be pathetic
and scam people even your own people
because you're losing your mind and
having a mental breakdown
go ahead if your religion allows for you
to go to do that goal you have your
religion we have ours and let the people
decide
who has more integrity
well I have been to uh two or three
African countries right and I say this
because in Africa people actually
practice Christianity bro and I don't
see many Christians practicing here
right they're just Christian by name
um and may Allah allow Islam to be the
strongest you know nation and loves to
win and uh you know long story short bro
when I met the Christians there they had
so much tradition so much love so much
values you know what I mean and we just
want to let everyone know that it's
clear that we're not attacking
Christians that's not what we're saying
we're just saying theologically Don is
practicing Christianity in the sense
that he does not have to have any
accountability if he just has belief
there's no Sharia that's dangerous bro
and this is an example of that and let
this be a lesson to anyone watching
um let this be a demonstration too about
what Rami said you know that a
percentage of everything we have raised
since day one right we agreed on this is
gonna go to a Masjid fund and
alhamdulillah we have enough money to
build a Masjid and we want to keep going
and everything will be documented we're
going to make Vlogs insha Allah
um but the reality is around me why
don't you tell them what we were talking
about before the stream bro
tell them tell them the idea that you
had bro just say we're gonna wrap this
up anyway before we recorded this
reaction video we discussed if this is
true if this is true that he actually
scammed someone Muslim or not out of 100
200 dollars
that we want to give this person their
money back just out of the goodness of
our hearts bro yeah and you know what
honestly it's not even a noble thing
because they're for example that brother
Ali that's been donating to the channel
I think he's donated himself over 200 to
our Channel after following us may Allah
bless him you know people support us and
uh they support the cause so this is not
out of really out of our pocket this is
out of the pockets of our support the
Muslims yeah the Muslims the people who
want to support our Channel this is a
part of being a Muslim and we're not
saying this you know because we're great
people we're amazing we're saying this
because Muslims hate Injustice speak the
truth even if it's against your own self
I think what he did was egregious and
disgusting I I hope insha Allah Allah
guides him and puts contentment in his
heart and brings him to Islam because
this is he's definitely losing his mind
here and it's I'm not joking I'm not
saying to be insulting it's actually
very sad for me to see any brother kind
of go through this and I think it's it's
it's it's really sad as soon as Rami had
that wonderful idea out of the goodness
of his heart I said I'm down bro but
then I thought about it and it's not
what's was I genuinely thought about it
and I was like bro if he scammed
supposedly wanted to scam Muslims but
then he scammed someone else but he
scammed someone out of 200 bucks in that
stream what makes us think he wouldn't
scam us and be like Oh I'm Sebastian
give me my 200. we send him the money
and then he's like look Muslims fall for
it again
you can't deal with clowns like this
with any any sort of Integrity bro but
you know that's still what we got to do
bro because we can't lose our upper hand
and the honor that Allah has granted us
over clowns like this bro 100 100 and at
the end of the day
if he you know did set it up and try
just to make his son look bad he still
accomplishes nothing because although he
feels like an anime villain I think
people very clearly can see he has no
integrity and he's very disingenuous and
at the end of the day no matter who you
are Muslim Christian atheist there's
something deep down within us that
despises these actions
and with that being said guys no I can't
give you the link for this but I'll post
a screenshot right now of the video it's
unlisted he took it down it's not public
anymore he's been doing this since this
whole thing started bro and uh long
story short on Friday homes Resorts will
be on the stream 6PM Eastern Standard
time this Friday September 2nd we will
end his career bro every single blunder
every single scientific error in the
Quran every single mistranslation
misinterpretation misguidance that he's
spewing bro
we're going to refute everything so
please stay tuned for that and make this
video go viral
the prophet saws mentioned that the
bridge between belief and disbelief is
abandoning Salah if you're struggling
with your Salah right now well we got
the perfect solution for you and that
solution is the Adan app this cell phone
we usually have it and is using us
instead of us using it but with the
Adana you can use it in perfect
alignment with your life the Adan app is
already used by 40 million Believers
around the world why because it caters
to your Islamic Lifestyle on top of the
Salat times you get their eyes thicker
the Islamic calendar Ramadan calendar
and iftar times Hajj and umra guide
Qibla finder and much more for free so
download the Adorn app no